good afternoon everybody i hope you're
all continuing to enjoy
the easter break and i know that over
this weekend millions of people
have been able to see loved ones for the
first time
in months and i want to thank you all
again for your patience because it is
really clear now that this is paying off
and
it's your collective efforts our
collective efforts
that have given us the crucial time and
space to vaccinate more than 31 million
people
and i'm pleased we've also been able to
support our overseas territories so that
gibraltar has become the first place in
the world
one of the first places in the world to
offer a vaccination to its entire
adult population and the net result of
your
efforts and of course with the of the
vaccine rollout
is that i can today confirm that from
monday the 12th of april we will move to
step two of our road map reopening
shops gyms zoos holiday campsites
personal care services like hairdressers
and of course
beer gardens and outdoor hospitality of
all kinds and on
monday the 12th i will be going to the
pub myself and
cautiously but irreversibly raising a
pint of beer
to my lips we're also increasing the
number of visitors to care homes from
one to two
to allow residents to see more of their
loved ones
we think that these changes are fully
justified
by the data which show that we're
meeting our four tests
for easing the lock down as chris will
shortly
explain but and you know i'm going to
say this
we can't be complacent we can see the
waves of sickness
afflicting other countries and we've
seen
how this story goes we still don't know
how strong the vaccine shield
will be when cases begin to rise as i'm
afraid that they will
and that's why we're saying please get
your vaccine or your second dose
when your turn comes and please
use the free nhs tests
even if you don't feel ill because
remember
one in three people with this virus
doesn't have any symptoms and you can
get these tests from your pharmacies
from pharmacies
or your local test site you can even
order them on gov dot uk and get home
deliveries as part of our road map we're
also
publishing today on gov uk the early
thinking
on our four reviews on the safe return
of major events on
social distancing the potential role
of covid status certification and
on the resumption of international
travel we set out our roadmap
and we're sticking in it and i want
to stress that we see nothing in the
present data
that makes us think that we will have to
deviate
from that roadmap but it's by being
cautious
by monitoring the data at every stage
and by following the rules remembering
hands face space
fresh air that we hope together to make
this
road map to freedom irreversible